bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat alors que le
gouvernement s'apprête à mettre en
oeuvre un des engagements de campagne du
candidat françois hollande à savoir
doter le pays du très haut débit
les sénateurs vont débattre cet
après-midi dans l'hémicycle du sénat de
la couverture numérique du territoire
quel rôle les collectivités
territoriales auront à jouer dans cet
aménagement
c'est la question que vous me posez les
sénateurs à fleur pellerin à la ministre
en charge de l'économie numérique
alors sans plus tarder direction
l'hémicycle pour suivre ce débat à bonne
science à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur
l'action des collectivités locales dans
le domaine de la couverture numérique du
territoire demande de la commission
sénatoriale pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois
la parole est à monsieur david assouline
président de la commission sénatoriale
pour l'application pour le contrôle de
l'application des lois
monsieur le président madame la ministre
chers collègues le débat thématique qui
s'ouvre cet après-midi porte que sur la
couverture numérique du territoire qui
est à la fois un des enjeux majeurs de
la compétitivité économique française
un élément fondamental de l'aménagement
contemporain du territoire est de plus
en plus un des vecteurs essentiels de la
communication des idées et de la culture
cette couverture numérique fait appel à
plusieurs types de réseaux depuis le
fils de cuivre héritier du téléphone
jusqu'à la fibre optique mais au coeur
des préoccupations des pouvoirs publics
l'objectif essentiel est de généraliser
l'accès au très haut débit ou thd
indispensable pour tirer le meilleur
parti des nouvelles technologies
numériques hors ca net un mystère pour
personne et ne devra porter messieurs
yves rome et pierre hérisson
dont je tiens à saluer le travail
important précis exigeant vont vous le
confirmer dans quelques instants
cet accès au très haut débit est encore
loin d'être à la hauteur des attentes et
des ambitions affichées depuis des
années dans ce domaine nous accusons
même un sérieux retard par rapport à
d'autres pays de l'union européenne elle
même moins avancés que d'autres grands
ensembles géographiques comme l'amérique
du nord ou l'asie
j'en veux pour preuve ce chiffre
éloquent notre pays occuperait en europe
le 23e rang sur 27 pour le taux de
pénétration du très haut débit dans une
europe elle-même équipé seulement à la
hauteur de 4% contre environ 70 % en
asie c'est pourquoi j'ai trouvé
judicieux que notre commission se
saisisse de cette question pour qu'elles
puissent sur la base d'un bilan objectif
de la situation c'est notre rôle
apporter sa contribution au débat en
cours au moment stratégique où le
gouvernement a lui même rendu publique
sa feuille de route pour le numérique
je tiens à ce propos a remercié le
président raymond vall et sa commission
du développement durable avec lesquels
nous avons travaillé en excellente
coordination sans entrer dans le détail
du travail de nos rapporteur jean
retient quelques points saillants qui
illustre bien me semble-t-il la démarche
de notre commission
le premier consiste à s'interroger sur
la pertinence du dispositif législatif
et réglementaire en vigueur
et c'est notre rôle en l'occurrence les
textes qui encadrent l'action des
opérateurs sont-ils réellement adaptés
notamment ce qui concerne l'intervention
des collectivités territoriales la
couverture numérique du territoire mais
en présente différents acteurs publics
ou privés dont l'état les collectivités
territoriales les grandes compagnies
privées et l'opérateur historique
plusieurs textes détermine leur rôle et
leurs rapports respectifs selon une
logique d'économie mixte qui semble-t-il
n'est pas propice à une bonne diffusion
du thd sur l'entrée sur l'ensemble du
territoire
schématiquement le modèle conçu par le
législateur repose aujourd'hui sur un
système de régulation distinguant deux
types de territoires numériques des
zones très denses où danse où se
développe une totale concurrence et les
autres portions du territoire soumises
un système de monopole
or ce schéma a montré ses limites avec
des opérateurs privés qui vise avant
tout à maximiser leurs profits dans des
zones très denses dès l'âge déjà
largement couverte et de l'autre des
collectivités territoriales réduite à
intervenir dans les zones les moins
rentables mais qui représente plus de la
moitié du territoire est presque 40% du
total des logements comme l'ont constaté
nous rapporteur il ya là un double
problème d'efficacité et d'équité qui
trouve sa source dans l'environnement
juridique où évoluent des opérateurs
comme le second problème qui hélas se
retrouve dans l'application de nombreux
autres textes concernent les
incertitudes sur le financement du
système
en effet un déploiement équitable du thd
sur l'ensemble du territoire
un pic des moyens financiers
considérables qui doivent être partagés
entre les acteurs publics et les
opérateurs privés
or sur ce point les indications
recueillies par nos rapporteur sur
l'effort de l'état pour aider les
collectivités locales ne porte pas
vraiment à l'optimisme
alors que les opérateurs privés ne
pourrons pas et nous voudrons pas
financer les investissements nécessaires
à la couverture des zones les moins
denses où les équipements se révèlent
les plus onéreux pour un nombre réduit
de points d'accès les rapporteurs évoque
à ce propos un investissement poussif
aggravée par certaines incohérences dans
l'attribution des responsabilités
à quoi bon afficher les engagements
ambitieux si les promesses bute sur
l'absence de moyens c'est souvent ce que
nous rencontrons de notre travail de
commission contrôle de l'application des
lois
cela risque de saper la confiance que
nos compatriotes peuvent placer dans des
textes et dans ceux qui les rédigent
nous mêmes un troisième point sur lequel
le président val a appelé notre
attention durant notre réunion de
commission et celui du déficit
d'information n'ont pas
les maires et les parlementaires sur les
réseaux existants c'est d'autant plus
regrettable que bien souvent ces
infrastructures ont été financés en
partie sur fonds publics
on objecte que la divulgation de ces
informations compromettrait le secret
des affaires
dans un contexte où les opérateurs se
livrent à une âpre concurrence
je pense néanmoins légitime que les
collectivités territoriales soit en
mesure d'obtenir toutes les informations
dont elles ont besoin sur la
cartographie des réseaux et des points
d'accès qui les servent leur territoire
ne serait ce que pour endiguer le départ
de certaines de leurs entreprises qui se
délocalise faut de l'accès au très haut
débit
au final notre bilan de l'application
des lois concernant l'action des
collectivités territoriales pour la
couverture numérique du territoire
demeure assez réservés je parle de la
législation existante
il s'agit d'un bilan politiquement
impartiale fait par le rapporteur
en effet dans cette commission nous
pratiquons depuis sa création une
méthode avec deux rapporteurs étant
issus de la majorité de l'opposition
pourtant leurs diagnostics se rejoint
pour constater que le scénario du succès
reste à écrire
madame la ministre voyez dans cette
analyse un encouragement
compte tenu de la diversité des intérêts
en présence
il est temps pour l'état d'assurer
pleinement son rôle de régulateur
d'abord en adaptant une politique
technologique plus clair ensuite en
définissant un cadre économique et
financier mieux en adéquation avec
l'objectif de cette politique et qui
favorise l'innovation
enfin en assurant une coordination plus
effective de tous les acteurs merci de
votre attention
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur yves rome co rapporteur
de la commission sénatoriale pour le
contrôle de l'application des lois
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues mon cher pierre hérisson
président de la république nous a confié
madame la ministre la mission de mettre
un oeuvre l'engagement qu'ils avaient
pris de doter notre pays d'une nouvelle
infrastructure permettant à tous les
français quel que soit le territoire où
il réside d'accéder au très haut débit
cet engagement représente un enjeu
politique fort celui de l'égalité des
opportunités offertes à chaque français
c'est aussi un choix majeur de politique
économique
celui d'abord d'élever le potentiel de
croissance du pays par les activités
induites et les gains de productivité et
donc le potentiel de compétitivité des
activités productrices
si l'on change d'ailleurs à ce que peut
rapporter à ce pays le développement de
l'e-administration celui aussi
d'augmenter le niveau de bien-être par
le développement produit de services de
solution susceptible de répondre aux
besoins des populations en effaçant la
distance le très haut débit doit
faciliter la résolution des handicaps
subies par des populations qui ne
bénéficient pas d effet d'agglomération
ce besoin d'ailleurs il doit aussi nous
épargner les incidences négatives des
concentrations géographiques que
connaissent bien les urbains épuisé par
la congestion des transports
je remercie donc une fois encore le
président assouline et le président
valdes avoir tout de suite compris que
notre haute assemblée se devait d'être
au rendez vous de ce qui doit être
beaucoup plus qu'une simple étape de la
modernisation du mairie de notre pays un
véritable changement
une mutation profonde de notre société
annonçant et garantissant le succès
d'une très hautes ambitions
ils ont le tout de suite la france n'a
pas pris cette affaire par le bon bout
précédent gouvernement a mis en place un
système peu satisfaisants et qui à ce
titre a suscité la perplexité
puis des tentatives de reformulation ici
même au sénat partager à chaque fois par
de très larges majorités des faits sont
là le rythme d'investissement dans les
infrastructures du très haut débit ainsi
que la sélection des territoires dans
ses investissements
témoigne laisse présager non seulement
un échec de l'équipement numérique du
pays
mais encore une aggravation la fracture
numérique
on dira que cette situation c'est aigre
dans une contre performance européenne
patente
je n'y trouve pas de raison de m'en
satisfaire permettait pas d'observer à
ce sujet que pendant que l'europe se
livrent à une dangereuse régression
quasi infantile et vous venez de le
constater vous même madame la ministre
le reste du monde avance puissamment il
faudrait d'ailleurs tout faire pour que
le très haut débit soit réellement
intégré comme une nouvelle frontière par
une europe qui a bien besoin d'un nouvel
élan
pendant que vous précisiez madame la
ministre ce qui allait devenir la
feuille de route
nous avons de l'autre côté voulu évaluer
la cohérence entre le cadre du
déploiement du très haut débit tel qu'il
a été défini et les compétences ouverte
collectivités territoriales ou si l'on
est moins positif mis à leur charge pour
moderniser l'équipement numérique de
notre pays je voudrais avant tout
rappeler un point tout à fait essentiel
le cadre qui valait pour le haut débit
innovations incrémentales par excellence
au coût de déploiement relativement
modérée est tout à fait inadaptée pour
le très haut débit qui est une
innovation radicale qu'il faut en
quelque sorte arraché aux terreaux
numérique c'est pour avoir feint de ne
pas le comprendre que le précédent
gouvernement a entériné un cadre de
régulation dont toutes les composantes
recélait la promesse de l'échec doublée
d'une fracture numérique qui venait
s'ajouter aux fractures territoriales
cruellement ressentie par les
populations des territoires les moins
denses de notre pays un cadre qui a un
effet acté la séparation du territoire
entre les zones d'intérêt commercial et
les zones concédé aux collectivités
territoriales l'interdiction de l'accès
à une péréquation de premier rang dans
laquelle les collectivités territoriales
aurait pu puiser les financements
nécessaires à leurs réseaux d'initiative
publique
le choix en fin de la concurrence entre
les opérateurs privés de l'écosystème
numérique atténuée toutefois par de trop
faibles outil de mutualisation un cadre
qui a été la porte ouverte à la
concentration des investissements sur
quelque partie du territoire à leur
duplication et à des stratégies de
marché et ce en toute considération de
l'objectif de la politique publique
d'équipements numériques du pays a
contrario madame la ministre
la feuille de route que vous avez conçu
répond largement à la préoccupation de
surmonter ses failles et de sortir du
cercle de l'inertie dans lequel le très
haut débit se trouvait c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les collectivités terian
et il me plaît de le souligner dans vie
ça vous voulez savoir madame la ministre
que sans rien devoir à l'état elles sont
prêtes à est vrai pour répondre à la
très forte et légitime demande sociale
qui s'exprime à partir des besoins de
nos concitoyens mais aussi et surtout de
nos entreprises sont également rassurés
par la réaffirmation de l'engagement
financier de l'état annoncé par le
président de la république lors de son
déplacement en auvergne
il témoigne une fidélité dont nous ne
doutions pas un seul instant à un
engagement qui est un élément important
de notre point de vue du pacte de
croissance conclut au bénéfice du pays
bien sûr il faudra continuer à conduire
une politique
agile et j insiste évolutive
l'obsolescence du réseau de cuivre devra
être rapidement décidé est programmée
c'est une condition sinequanone du
succès du très haut débit
nous suivrons avec attention bien
entendu
l'expérimentation conduite à palaiseau
et nous attendrons que ces résultats
soient pleinement transparent
nous serons également très attentif aux
travaux de la mission de vous avez
annoncé la création sur ce point et à
laquelle il faut y insister que le
parlement soit associée de près et je
dirais de très près le basculement du
cuivre vers la fibre doit être
accompagnée des mesures nécessaires pour
que le statut d'opérateur d'opérateurs
des collectivités territoriales ne soit
pas un handicap structurel pour leurs
projets disons le nettement les
collectivités territoriales sans aucun
doute les investisseurs les plus
disposés à contribuer à l'atteinte des
ambitions d'une politique nationale
d'équipement numérique
il faut tout faire pour ne pas les
décourager
ce qui veut dire qu'il faut madame la
ministre
les sécuriser et les aider nous
attendons de la régulation qu'elles
consolident les perspectives financières
des investissements des collectivités
le choix de la fibre qui est le vôtre et
qui répond au voeu du sénat j'en suis
sûr devra se traduire par une définition
très précise des situations où un
panachage technologique s'avérera
justifiée car pratiquement nécessaire
plus globalement nous devons partir d'un
objectif devrait très haut débit écarté
la tentation de l'affadissement
technologiques telles que l'europe vient
de l'indiquer en fixant à 30
le niveau d'atteinte du très haut débit
il y va a bien entendu de la sobriété
financière de l'équipement numérique à
long terme
il y va aussi de la cohérence du projet
de la fibre pour tous et de la
crédibilité de la politique industrielle
politique industrielle il implique le
calibrage du financement public devra
évoluer afin de tenir compte des
investissements effectivement réalisés
par les opérateurs privés
nous tenons beaucoup madame la ministre
à ce qu'il tienne plaît
man compte de la nécessité d'apporter
aux collectivités territoriales les
ressources nécessaires à une égalité
réelle des territoires les taux de
subventionnement par l'état devront être
modulée en conséquence afin que l'effort
contributif des collectivités
territoriales soit le plus égale
possible il faut aussi envisager que les
fonds publics consacrés par l'état au
très haut débit doivent être mises à
niveau à ce stade le bouclage financier
de la feuille de route n'implique pas de
mobilisation des prélèvements
obligatoires
mais il ne faut pas insulter l'avenir le
rapport que nous avons proposé au sénat
envisage un certain nombre d'hypothèses
qui procède de cet état d'esprit on y
trouve quelques pistes de financement
qui pourront être utiles en cas de
nécessité et je suis certain qu'il
faudra les mettre en oeuvre
à un moment donné rappelons nous que la
france sans doute le pays au monde où
les tarifs des abonnements numériques
sont les plus bas au monde
sachant vérifier que le surplus du
consommateur engendrés par la
concurrence tarifaire et durable et
qu'il ne se fait pas par des retards
dans le rythme d'investissement comme on
peut observer
n'oublions pas que les passagers
clandestins des infrastructures du net
existe aussi bien que ceux des maisons
d'édition et qu'en plus ils sont
fréquemment localisés dans des zones
fiscal que l'exemple chypriote devrait
nous inciter à ramener à la raison
madame la ministre vous avez commencé de
donner une vraie substance à notre
préconisations de retour de l'état
stratège
n'oubliez pas que celui ci à plus de
responsabilité que de prérogatives est
en particulier il lui faut concilier une
légitime préoccupation de cohérence et
des libertés locales sans lesquels le
formidable dynamisme des collectivités
risque d'être étouffée
plutôt que de nous contraindre de nous
enfoncer dans des cadres
conçu dans les bureaux parisiens madame
la ministre libérez nous monsieur le
président j'en aurai terminé en
remerciant la conférence des présidents
d'avoir inscrit ce débat à notre ordre
du jour et en formulant le souhait que
notre haute assemblée puissent
persévérer de façon
continue l'exercice de son rôle de
conseil de surveillance de la politique
publique qui doit nous permettre de
rejoindre la frontière technologique du
très haut débit et plus largement du
numérique en tous ses aspects je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur la parole
est à monsieur pierre hérisson co
rapporteur de la commission sénatoriale
pour le contrôle de l'application des
lois
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
mon cher yves rome pour répondre à l
appel de tout à l'heure yves rome a tout
dit déjà beaucoup dit et par image
rempli le vert que nous essayons de
compléter pour avoir pour étancher la
soif de haut débit et de près aux débits
sur notre territoire
en cet après midi où quelques signes
printanier arrive je crois que nous
pouvons aussi s'attacher et nous
attacher aux saisons madame la ministre
comme l'a précisé le président assouline
tout à l'heure la préciser un
parlementaire de la majorité un
parlementaire de l'opposition donc pas
précaution verbal probablement que mon
intervention sera peut-être moins
feutrée que l'a été celle de yves rome
mais le souci étant à travers la
commission d'application des lois de
faire ressortir un certain nombre de
critiques et de réalité que nous
connaissons sur le terrain et que
d'autres exprimeront ici des inquiétudes
voire des incompréhensions en matière de
financement tel est le sens de mon
propos
le précédent président de la république
avait fixé l'ambition de doter les
français du très haut débit à un horizon
de 2025
le candidat françois hollande a fait un
peu de surenchère et raccourcit le terme
à 2022
campagne électorale oblige je ne ferai
pas plus de commentaires sur ce point je
crois que pourtant le slogan le très
haut débit pour douce pour tout se
révèle déjà une forme de pavillons de
complaisance peut-être sous lequel
peuvent naviguer bien des réalités
pour ceux qui croyaient qu'il s'agissait
de leur ouvrir l'accès à un débit
minimal de 100 mégabits seconde
il va falloir déchanter vous n'avez pas
été pour rien dans cette croyance madame
la ministre en répétant à l'envi
qu'avec le très haut débit il s'agissait
de la fibre pour tous déjà l'arcep avait
abaissé sa norme de référence en
adoptant un critère de 30 mégabits des
décoder connu la position de la
commission européenne qui n'a cessé de
réduire et de diminuer en passant par la
case 50
la définition du très haut débit
première observation sur lequel nous
pouvons tous nous rejoindre et pour
lequel il faut contester
nous ne pouvons pas accepter alors que
vous revenez madame la ministre d'un
pays qui vous est cher où on parle en
gia je crois que nous discuter
aujourd'hui de 20 30 40 50 méga bits
seconde nous sommes véritablement décalé
par rapport à la réalité de ce que peut
représenter l'avenir
néanmoins septembre n'apparaisse comme
un sceau made accessible pour nos
compatriotes vivant en dehors des
agglomérations il nous faudra rapidement
clarifier vos choix technologiques et la
géographie de leur diffusion
clarifications indispensables pour les
collectivités territoriales qui doivent
être promise à même de mettre en oeuvre
des projets réalistes mais aussi des
projets sécurisé et c'est bien là un des
deux problèmes je suis personnellement
favorable à un panaché h technologique
claire qui pour s'inscrire dans la
perspective d'une ambition de débits
élevés me semble imposer par le bon sens
et le souci d'économie des deniers
publics
nous y reviendrons dans quelques
instants mais je suis aussi attaché
comme il voit mme à ce que l'état ne
laisse pas les collectivités
territoriales prendre des risques
inconsidérés
vous avez indiqué madame la ministre
assumer l'héritage que vous avez trouvé
à votre arrivée vous avez tourné le dos
à la table rase ce qui est un choix fort
pour lequel je vous salue et que je
salue cette position il n'en reste pas
moins que l'expérience a montré que la
combinaison de ce que nous avons appelé
un oligopole déséquilibrée avec un
monopole contrarié
celui des collectivités locales a
résisté aux instruments mis en place par
le régulateur et aboutit à des
situations sous-optimale le système de
régulation mises en place par la
précédente législature qui repose sur un
processus de ré actualisation continue
des analyses de marché avaient pour
vocation de corriger les imperfections
observer si nécessaire par l'analyse que
nous avons proposé dans notre rapport il
ressort clairement que les incitations à
la mutualisation doivent être renforcées
ça va accepter des multi des deux
publications inutile et que la
protection des investissements des
collectivités territoriales doivent être
améliorées il s'agit vraiment d'une
urgence je ne suis pas sûr que la
feuille de route soit au rendez vous de
tous de toutes ces exigences
mais chemin faisant elle peut être
renforcée nous verrons bien si la
perspective de voir les collectivités
prendre le relais de leur engagement
dans la zone amis de exercera à l'effet
sur les opérateurs privés le saurons
attentif aux conditions dans lesquelles
vous assurez la cohérence entre les
différents réseaux de fibre de cuivre de
câbles ou d'autres technologies
nous ne voyons pas ce que vous proposez
pour assurer aux collectivités
territoriales une position commerciale
assez forte pour élever la disposition à
payer des opérateurs auxquels elles
offrent leurs projets d'infrastructures
au demeurant nous voudrions que vous
nous convainquent et que les zones les
plus déshéritées du numérique seront
aussi les premières servies dans les
objectifs intermédiaires pour 2017 d'une
couverture de la moitié des foyers
français pour le très haut débit ou si
j'ai bien compris pour le haut débit de
qualité
il faudra nous dire ce que vous entendez
par là combien de foyers ruraux
avez-vous pour ambition de rendre
éligibles ceux là aussi il faut nous le
dire madame la ministre
permettez moi d'ajouter que nous serons
très vigilants sur les indicateurs de
votre politique et que l'atteinte d'un
taux d'éligibilité ne nous suffira pas
nous veillerons à ce qu'il ne s'agisse
pas d'une éligibilité de façade si j'ose
d
et que le très haut débit ne dorment pas
sur les trottoirs de paris de lyon ou de
lille
mais précisément parce le seuil et monte
dans les appartements et équipes les
entreprises
pour cela nous le savons il faudra des
financements sur ce point madame la
ministre il ya de quoi nourrir quelques
inquiétudes
je m'ouvre d'une première d'entre elles
assez technique
pouvez-vous nous rassurer sur les effets
du basculement vers la fibre sur le
produit de la composante télécoms de
l'hiver il y va d'une recette des
collectivités territoriales de plus de
400 millions d'euros en 2012
au delà le besoin de financement public
est au coeur de l'équation
il dépend des équilibres économiques qui
conditionneront les retours commerciaux
des investissements incidemment je
relève l'intérêt qui s'attacherait ce
que d'ailleurs ce qu'ailleurs comme pour
la question qui nous occupe se développe
une réflexion de fond sur la
contribution des réformes structurelles
à la résolution de notre contrainte
financière
cela étant dit je m'interroge sur le
cadrage financier que vous nous avez
présenté respecte-t-il les obligations
concurrentielles européennes
comme vous le savez l'estimation du coût
du déploiement du très haut débit varie
considérablement se fonder sur un
chiffre de 20 milliards d'euros
comme vous le faites implique des choix
technologiques qui écarte la mise à
disposition de la fibre pour une
proportion élevée de nos concitoyens je
vous serais reconnaissant de nous
préciser quel est le taux des gilles
d'éligibilité à la fibre que vous visez
réellement en nous donnant toutes les
informations nécessaires pour que
territoire par territoire nous soyons
informés de votre cible
par ailleurs il faut considérer que nos
concitoyens ou individuellement assumer
le financement du dernier segment de
raccordement et comment considérez vous
ce choix avec un principe dès
l'égalisation du pouvoir d'achat du très
haut débit
qui assumera le coût de l'extinction du
cuivre au madame la ministre
avez vous quelques estimations de la
perte d'actifs que cela représente pour
l'opérateur historique inclus et vous
secoue dans les 20 milliards
je crains que non enfin que fort et vous
si les 14 milliards que vous escomptez
voir les opérateurs privés a fait
investir dans la nouvelle infrastructure
ne sont pas engager la feuille de route
évoque la prise de relais par les
collectivités territoriales
certes aidé par l'état à quel niveau
sans doute répondre et vous qu'il ne
s'agit que d'une éventualité mais elle
votre devoir est de gouverner donc de
prévoir et vous avez déjà envisagée que
si déplaisante éventualité se présente
puisque vous le savez le projet de
budget européen a littéralement déserté
le champ du numérique dans les 8
milliards d'abattement de crédit sur 9
milliards projetés il nous reste un
milliard et on en parle bien peu et on
en parle bien peu combien de pertes de
ressources pour les les réseaux
d'intérêts publics élaboré en france que
forêt vous pour compenser ce manque de
financement c'est une question
essentielle avant de conclure je
voudrais monsieur le président remercia
mon tour la conférence des présidents
d'avoir inscrit ce débat à notre ombre
du jour ce faisant nous poursuivons dans
le chemin de mon excellent collègue yves
rome avec bien entendu sous la
présidence de pardon de monsieur
assouline avec qui j'ai eu un véritable
grand plaisir à travailler sur le très
haut débit a souhaité que le sénat
continue d'emprunter le chemin qui fait
de notre haute assemblée
mais encore que la chambre où l'on
contrôle l'application des lois celle où
l'indispensable évaluation des
politiques publiques se fait au service
et dans la dignité démocratique de notre
pays
et finalement pour le bien public je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite du débat à la parole est à
monsieur hervé maurey pour le groupe
udi uc
à
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
permettez moi tout d'abord de saluer le
travail de nos collègues pierre hérisson
et yves rome je souffre créé il ya une
grande partie de ce qui a été dit y
compris par le président assouline un
peu moins sur l'aspect feuille de route
du gouvernement mais j'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir
le rapport de messieurs rome hérisson
s'inscrit dans la tradition sénatoriale
qui fait de notre assemblée chargée de
représenter les territoires un acteur
majeur du combat pour le numérique
je rappellerai le rôle du sénat dans la
possibilité reconnu dès 2004 aux
collectivités d'intervenir dans le
domaine du numérique
je rappellerai la proposition de loi de
notre collègue pintât qui a donné lieu à
la loi contre la fracture numérique loi
de 2009 qui a créé le fonds
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
fond qui est toujours sans fond et dans
le prolongement de cette loi j'avais été
chargé d'un rapport remis au premier
ministre en 2010 qui s'intitulait
réussir le déploiement du très haut
débit une nécessité pour la france et
qui proposait des pistes pour alimenter
ce fonds
quelques mois plus tard la commission de
l'économie du développement durable et
de l'aménagement du territoire adopté à
l'unanimité un rapport que je présentais
qui s'intitulait aménagement numérique
du territoire passer de la parole aux
actes qui dressait un constat très
lucide et sans aucune complaisance à
l'égard de la situation de la france en
matière de numérique et qui proposait au
travers de 33 mesure des solutions pour
y remédier et c'est justement pour
passer de la parole aux actes qu avec
mon collègue philippe leroy nous avons
quelques mois plus tard déposé une
proposition de loi qui a été adopté à
une large majorité de cette assemblée
avec le concours de mes collègues du
groupe socialiste que je remercie à
nouveau cette proposition de loi qui
reprenait les conclusions de ce rapport
avait notamment pour objectif de
garantir un véritable haut débit pour
tous à 2 mégabits seconde à partir du 31
décembre 2013 et à 5 mégabits seconde
à partir du 31 décembre 2015 parce que
parler de très haut débit c'est bien
mais quand on en parle à des territoires
qui n'ont même pas de haut débit c'est
indécent cette proposition doit avait
également pour objectif de redéfinir les
critères de couverture mobile de
téléphonie mobile puisque aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de territoires sont
censés être couverts par la téléphonie
mobile et dans les faits ne le sont pas
et puis de modifier le programme
national très haut débit en
rééquilibrant la relation entre les
opérateurs et les collectivités locales
au profit de celle ci puisque nous en
que vos oignons tous à l'époque en tout
cas il y à un déséquilibre flagrant dans
la relation opérateurs collectivités
locales puisque les opérateurs
finalement sont totalement maître du jeu
ils vont là où ils volent ils ne sont
absolument pas tenu par leurs
déclarations selon lesquelles ils vont
déployer sur un territoire mais en
revanche le sol c'est d'annoncer qu'ils
déploieront sur un territoire prive les
collectivités de ce droit au déploiement
et c'est ainsi qu'il y ait aujourd'hui à
peu près 3600 communes qui sont gelés
à l'époque mon collègue ibrahim trouvé
que nous n'étions pas que nous n'étions
pas allés assez loin
mais depuis il a évolué peu après ce
vote
peu après ce vote un nouveau président
et un nouveau gouvernement est entrée en
fonction et naïvement je me suis dit
le changement c'est maintenant et c'est
dans cette année c'est dans cet état
d'esprit madame la ministre que vous
m'avez que vous avez bien voulu me
recevoir au mois de juin c'est dans cet
état d'esprit que je vous ai dit que je
soutiendrai toutes les mesures que vous
pourriez prendre et qui irait dans la
bonne direction parce que je considère
qu'en la matière il faut savoir dépasser
les clivages politiques et que l'intérêt
général en matière d'aménagement
numérique du territoire doit primer sur
toute autre considération
je dois dire que mes illusions ont été
de courte durée et la manière dont a été
examiné la proposition de loi
sénatoriale à l'assemblée nationale le
22 novembre dernier a définitivement
sonné le glas de mes illusions
puisque vous avez eu à l'égard du
travail sénatorial madame la ministre
des mots extrêmement durs vous avez
qualifié notre proposition de loi je
vous cite d'idéologique et court
termiste vous avez jugé que les mesures
que nous avions adopté à la quasi
unanimité du sénat était inutile
inefficace et poser des problèmes de
constitutionnalité et vous avez
également dit que le texte était sous
dimensionné et décalé bel hommage rendu
au travail du sénat et ce qui m'a frappé
dans l'examen de cette proposition de
loi c'est que vous avez déposé des
amendements de suppression de tous les
articles
y compris de certains articles qui
émanait de mes collègues socialistes
testons et camani en employant mot pour
mot quasiment les arguments qu'ils
étaient ceux de votre prédécesseur eric
besson arguments qui sont bien connus
parce que ce sont les arguments des
opérateurs et donc de cette date j'ai dû
conclure qu'il n'y aurait pas de
changements mais uniquement un
renoncement et la suite des événements
m'a malheureusement confirmé cette
analyse plutôt que vous appuyez sur le
travail des parlementaires vous avez
nommé un fonctionnaire monsieur carotte
que je n'ai pas eu le bonheur de
rencontrer mais qui a fait un travail
qui nous a été présenté au cours d'une
réunion dite de concertation au cours de
laquelle ceux qui étaient là ont pu le
constater il était impossible de
s'exprimer nous étions une centaine dans
une pièce avec un créneau de parole
totalement limités et donc j'ai renoncé
à m'exprimer et je vous ai adressées par
écrit mais remarque je n'ai pas eu de
réponse mais là aussi je suis habitué
sur le fond qu'en est il de cette
feuille de route parce que finalement
c'est ça l'essentiel aujourd'hui cette
feuille de route d'abord elle n'aborde
pas la question du haut débit
alors qu'encore un quart des français
n'ont même pas une connexion à 2
mégabits seconde est que vous convenez
vous même qu'il faudrait que les
français et des connexions de l'ordre de
3,4 megabit secondes
elle n'aborde pas non plus la question
de la téléphonie mobile alors que de
nombreux territoires n'en sont toujours
pas pourvus et sont considérés comme
couvert c'est là le pire
dans le département dont je suis élu aux
yeux de l'arcep et de la datar il n'y a
aucun problème de couverture numérique
du territoire en matière de téléphonie
mobile
je vous invite à venir dans le
département de l'eure nous n'aurons pas
aller bien loin pour rencontrer des
zones non couvertes sur le très haut
débit
vous aviez annoncé et nous nous en
réjouissions le retour de l'état
stratège c'était effectivement ce que
nous reprochons au plan du précédent
gouvernement
mais dans les faits il n'en est rien
vous vous contentez de créer une série
de comités alors il ya un comité très
technique c'est très bien il était dans
la proposition doit il y un observatoire
c'est peut-être bien il y à des comités
locaux sont totalement inutiles voire
négatif mais pour le reste l'état ne
retrouve aucun pouvoir
il n'ya même pas il ne se porte même pas
garant du bon déploiement et c'est ça
qu'il aurait fallu c'est qu'il y ait au
moins l'état qui se portent garants du
déploiement parce qu'en réalité selon
les départements
selon que l'on a ou pas des conseils
généraux qui sont dynamiques qui vont de
l'avant qui mettent en place des
politiques ambitieuses
il y a une couverture numérique du
territoire où il n'y en a pas et donc
dans les années qui viennent la fracture
numérique ne fera que s'accentuer et sur
le rééquilibrage entre opérateurs et
collectivités locales
vous envisagez certes la
contractualisation vous aviez condamné à
l'assemblée nationale
mais sans vouloir que le non respect de
cette contractualisation soient
sanctionnés et dès lors que la
contractualisation plutôt son non
respect n'est pas sanctionné et bien la
contractualisation devient sans effet
vous n'évoquez pas non plus la
possibilité de projets intégrés qui est
pourtant demandé par les collectivités
locales pour pouvoir faire une
péréquation entre les territoires
rentable et ceux qui ne le sont pas
alors que l'autorité de la concurrence a
dit que c'était possible
dans le même esprit vous réaffirmer la
primauté de la fibre et nous nous en
réjouissons
mais vous distinguez bien le très haut
débit objectif 2022 de la fibre à terme
sans que l'on sache ce que cela veut
dire mais le fait de différencier
l'objectif 2022 de la fibre à terme
montre bien que les choses ne sont pas
aussi clairs que vous le dites
enfin pour ne pas être trop long puisque
le temps est compté
sur le financement le chou est absolu et
et mon collègue hérisson l'a dit en
termes plus choisis que moi si vous
chiffré à 20 milliards le déploiement
chiffre qui peut être acceptée vous
n'indiquez pas comment vous y
parviendrez vous évoquez un apport de 6
milliards des opérateurs mais comment
les opérateurs métro 6 milliards en 10
ans alors que de mettre 300 millions par
an vous évoquez une participation des
collectivités locales qui serait du même
ordre mais comment les collectivités
locales qui sont étranglés par à la une
baisse des dotations pourrons y parvenir
et vous évoquez péniblement 3 milliards
qui seraient mis sur la table par l'état
alors je voudrais dire en conclusion que
le projet du gouvernement en la matière
ne répondent nullement aux objectifs qui
ont été affirmées par les rapporteurs
dans leurs travaux ni dans les travaux
qui ont été menées précédemment par le
sénat et j'avoue plaindront beaucoup mes
collègues de la majorité avec lesquels
j'ai bien travaillé sur ces dossiers qui
aujourd'hui comme ils roms sont obligés
de faire semblant qu'il y aurait une
différence entre le plan besson et le
plan pèlerins la réalité elle nous a été
livré par le président de l'arcep en
commission qui a dit je le cite
nous sommes dans la continuité et c'est
bien ce que je regrette c'est que nous
sommes dans la continuité et pas plus
que l'on aurait atteint l'objectif fixé
par nicolas sarkozy en 2025
on atteindra l'objectif fixé par
françois hollande en 2022 et je voudrais
donc vous dire ma colère que le
gouvernement ne met pas en place les
dispositions nécessaires pour relever ce
défi du numérique dont notre économie et
nos territoires ont besoin et je
voudrais dire qu'en fait on observe sur
ce dossier ce que finalement on observe
sur à peu près tous les dossiers le
gouvernement commence par critiquer ses
prédécesseurs acto un acte 2 il nomme
une commission
acte iii il annonce des moyens
totalement inadapté et acte iv et bien
au bout de quelques temps on confiant
que les objectifs ne seront pas atteints
et bien je vous dis madame la ministre
amah chers collègues aujourd'hui
solennellement qu'il n'y aura pas de
très haut débit pour tous sur 2022 et
que cet engagement de françois hollande
comme de nombre
autre ne sera pas tenu je vous remercie
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur stéphane mazars pour le groupe
rdse
ce président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues l'accès aux nouvelles
technologies de l'information et de la
communication est vitale pour l'ensemble
de nos territoires et cela est d'autant
plus vrai pour les territoires ruraux
qui vont devoir dépendre de plus en plus
des services fournis à distance et ce
pour éviter leur déclin je remercie mes
collègues drôme et pierre hérisson pour
la qualité de leurs rapports qui nous
permet d'avoir ce débat au sein de cet
hémicycle le sénat assemblée
représentante des collectivités
territoriales des territoires nous
entendons parfois des comparaisons entre
le déploiement du thé au très haut débit
en france ou en europe et les avancées
impressionnante des pays émergents
cependant nous ne pouvons pas comparer
des pays qui avaient peu
d'infrastructures câblée au départ et
des pays industrialisés qui vont devoir
opérer le basculement du cuivre à la
finale au lieu de regretter et de
regarder de manière figer le retard
perdu de répéter que la france n'occupe
que le 23e la 23e place de l'union
européenne en taux de pénétration du
très haut débit
nous devons nous tourner vers l'avenir
et planifier dès à présent le
déploiement accéléré de la fibre sans
compromettre toutefois les possibilités
d'évolution future sur lesquels il faut
rester attentif notamment en ce qui
concerne les technologies non filaire si
nous pouvons constater que les usages
sont multiples aujourd'hui seul e demain
seront infinie et créeront des besoins
croissants en débit descendant et encore
plus en divine montant les entreprises
savent et conditions le d'ailleurs déjà
le choix de leurs implantations à la
qualité de la bande passante
c'est donc un enjeu important
d'aménagement de notre territoire
les salariés de ces mêmes entreprises de
plus en plus nomades organise des
visioconférences à plusieurs
interlocuteurs tout en échangeant des
données importantes et en procédant à de
lourds de sauvegarde
c'est donc un devoir pour lui pour les
autorités publiques de leur proposer
aujourd'hui les instruments
indispensables à leur compétitivité
le haut débit grande révolution des
années 2000 encore suffisant pour le
particulier est devenu déjà obsolète
pour la plupart des entreprises où en
serons-nous dans les dix prochaines
années avec usage accru division
conférence du télétravail de l'éducation
à distance les effets doivent devenir
fluide c'est l'attractivité même de la
france qui est en jeu et l'accès à
internet est encore bien insuffisants au
regard des évolutions économiques et
sociétales en cours et à venir à de
nombreuses reprises dans cet hémicycle
nous avons déploré l'absence
d'infrastructures de transport dans les
espaces ruraux
or il est évident que l'accès au très
haut débit pourrait participer à l'heure
des intervenants aujourd'hui des
entreprises qui pourraient venir
s'installer sur certains territoires
porte le regard ailleurs faute
d'infrastructures les citoyens qui
pourraient venir vivre également sur ces
territoires qui rentrait sur des projets
de vie pourtant l'accès au numérique
représente une diminution des
déplacements une réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre une améliorer
nos meilleurs répartition de la
population sur le territoire national
une meilleure visibilité de nos
entreprises à l'étranger
mes chers collègues le numérique
concentre l'espoir de nos concitoyens et
de nos entreprises et en dépit de tous
les efforts péniblement fournis par les
collectivités territoriales les
opérateurs refusent tout déploiement en
raison du manque de rentabilité
car il est plus coûteux de les irriguer
en fibre optique
les collectifs les collectivités n'ont
pas eu le choix que de se saisir et de
pallier à l'absence d'investissements
privés et de réelles stratégies de la
part de l'état il convient à ce titre de
féliciter les initiatives locales
auxquelles l'état se permet constamment
de demander des efforts financiers alors
que les collectivités maîtriser la
gestion publique
bien avant que l'état n'ait pris
l'initiative de réduire ses propres
dépenses le numérique en est un parfait
exemple
le président de la république a eu
raison de saisir rapidement du problème
en instaurant une mission sur le très
haut débit et dont la feuille de route a
été présenté au mois de février dernier
l'état doit enfin prendre en main l
aménagement du territoire et renforcer
la coordination des actions locales pour
assurer une cohérence au niveau national
la feuille de route dressée par le plan
très haut débit propose donc d'investir
20 milliards d'euros pour le déploiement
du très haut débit en dix ans et ce pour
permettre à l'ensemble de la population
d'y accéder à l'horizon 2022
un tiers de ce financement sera dédié
aux collectivités les moins denses et
sera confidences et entre l'état et ces
dernières il est vrai que l'intervention
publique sera encore nécessaire pour ne
pas laisser une grande partie de la
population de côté la création d'une
taxe sur les abonnements pour contribuer
au basculement du cuivre à la fibre
reste une solution à envisager pour
financer ses projets sans lesquels une
grande partie de la france à savoir les
zones non rentables risquerait de perdre
les bénéfices d'une technologie qui
rapproche les territoires et ses acteurs
de la compétitivité du développement
économique et des services publics
peut-être pourriez-vous madame la
ministre nous faire part de la réflexion
du gouvernement à la matière si cet
objectif hautement louable doit être
salué une remarque s'impose où en
serons-nous du point de vue
technologique dans dix ans d'autres
révolutions technologiques auront lieu
il y a un peu plus de 10 ans nous
n'utilisons pas le wifi et nous ne
disposions pas de la 3g
ainsi on peut regretter que le plan très
haut débit évoque un peu trop rapidement
le rôle des réseaux sans fil moyens
complémentaires à la fibre qui
fournissent également du haut et du très
haut débit
alors qu'il pourrait assurer un rôle de
transition en attendant le déploiement
de la fibre les réseaux mobiles sont
aussi à l'avenir et nos usages le
prouvent ordinateur smartphone tablette
imprimante tout se connectent sans fil
en l'absence de réflexion sur les
réseaux mobiles
nous risquons une nouvelle fois madame
le ministre d'être en retard j'espère
madame la ministre que vous pourrez
également nous apporter plus de
précisions à ce sujet ainsi que sur la
faisabilité financière de cette fouille
feuilles gouvernementale ambitieuse
feuille de route madame la ministre
et vous l'aurez compris qui est
accueillie très favorablement très
favorablement parce que c'est une
solution un moyen un signe fort pour
réduire aujourd'hui ce que nous
dénonçons sur nos territoires c'est à
dire cette fracture numérique et cette
inégalité entre les territoires dont
nous sommes issus ici au sénat
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur andré gattolin pour le groupe
écologie monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues permettant
en premier lieu de saluer le travail de
mes collègues et brom et pierre hérisson
et puisque lors même au sénat est un
anglicisme je dirais que ce daboll play
gagnant de rapporteur a remarqué mon
blog
remarquablement mise en lumière les
blocages et les difficultés se
rapportant au déploiement du très haut
débit en france
le plan établi sous le quinquennat du
précédent gouvernement se fixait comme
objectif de couvrir l'intégralité des
foyers en thd d'ici à 2025
nous en sommes très loin puisque
actuellement seuls deux millions de
logements sont raccordés en fibre
optique notre retard par rapport aux
autres pays de l'union européenne et
sérieux d'autant que les territoires
aujourd'hui équipés dans notre pays sont
concentrés dans les zones les plus
urbanisées
face à ce constat le groupe écologiste
suit avec attention les orientations
stratégiques qui ont été affichées par
le président de la république à clermont
ferrand le 20 février dernier
la couverture en thd de l'ensemble du
territoire en 2022 a constitué un de ses
engagements de campagne
pour ce faire il a donc récemment appelé
à un investissement public et privé de
20 milliards d'euros dans les dix
prochaines années
l'ambition numérique du gouvernement
repose sur la volonté de réduire la
fracture numérique d'améliorer la
compétitivité des entreprises et
d'offrir une meilleure offre de services
numériques dans les zones peu denses
le groupe écologiste partagent
l'objectif général d'assurer l'égalité
des territoires
en effet en l'absence d'infrastructures
numériques adaptés l'attractivité des
territoires décline et favorise le
départ ou la non-installation d'activité
à forte valeur ajoutée dans ces zones
il s'agit cependant d'un investissement
considérable qui fait porter une lourde
charge aux pouvoirs publics sur les 20
milliards dédiés à l'ambition numérique
du gouvernement
l'investissement public devrait
représenter environ 6 milliards d'euros
une somme dont l'état assumerait la
moitié du financement aux côtés des
collectivités de cale dans les zones
jugées les moins
rentable dans la période de crise
financière économique que nous
traversons nous devrons donc nous
assurer que nous allons opérer les bons
choix technologiques et trouver les
systèmes de financement les plus
pertinents compte tenu de l'évolution
des besoins en matière de numérique
la fibre optique est sans doute
aujourd'hui la technologie la plus
appropriée
mais l'objectif d'une couverture totale
du territoire en thd est elle réaliste
économiquement et ce à sa charge la plus
équitablement répartis car en l'état
général de l'économie du numérique ces
investissements in fine et profiteront
en premier lieu aux géants de l'internet
les entreprises très habile pour
s'approprier la valeur des contenus
diffusés via le numérique et qui se
dispense par ailleurs d'acquitter la tva
ou l'impôt sur les sociétés en france je
ne citerai pas de noms vous voyez de
quelle société je veux parler
le rapport colin colin sur la fiscalité
du numérique a d'ailleurs souligné cet
effet induit en pointant que le
développement du très haut débit site
promet également d'être facteur
d'accélération radicale du mouvement de
transformation de l'économie issu de la
révolution numérique y compris la
domination des grandes sociétés
américaines du numérique et leur montée
en puissance dans la chaîne de valeur de
tous les secteurs de l'économie
par ailleurs si la couverture en haut
débit du pays est essentielle pour
lutter contre la fracture territoriale
et contre la fracture numérique
elle ne se solutionne cependant pas à
elles seules ces questions les
inégalités en matière d'accès et surtout
d' usage du numérique ne serait ne
vieillissent pas en effet à une question
une simple question de tuyaux il existe
aussi des disparités très fortes en
matière de qualité des échos des
équipements personnels et familiaux et
des coûts d'accès à certaines
informations ou à certains logiciels
des disparités existent aussi dans le
domaine de la protection et de la
sécurisation des données personnelles ou
professionnelles ainsi qu'en matière
d'intensité d'usagé de nature
d'utilisation du numérique
concernant la fracture territoriale
notre vaste et beau pays n'a
malheureusement n'est malheureusement
pas en 3 caussols disparités
et un accès très inégal aux
infrastructures numériques
loin de moi évidemment l'idée de
minimiser l'importance et le rôle
qu'elles joueront demain pour la
compétitivité de la france et la
revitalisation économique de ces
territoires
mais cette question de la fracture
numérique territoriale ne doit pas être
isolé de la question plus large de la
disparition ou de la rationalisation
excessive de certains services publics
de la fermeture des commerces de la
raréfaction des activités sociales sur
des zones immenses de notre territoire
il faut donc en matière de fracture
territoriale réfléchir globalement c'est
à dire en termes d'éco système et ne pas
se focaliser exclusivement sur la
question de l'aménagement numérique
car il ne faut pas se le cacher quand la
ressource est rare et les besoins
nombreux et variés nous devons procéder
à des arbitrages complexe budgétaire et
financier notamment afin de ne pas
déshabiller paul pour habiller jacques
quand je vois l'investissement que le
conseil territoriale de
saint-pierre-et-miquelon vient d'un bien
j'ai pour l'aménagement numérique du
petit archipel je me demande si une
meilleure desserte en transport une
forte amélioration des infrastructures
sanitaires et éducatives n'aurait pas dû
être tout aussi prioritaire
la question est donc à la fois
stratégique et financière elle nécessite
d'abord d'avoir une idée précise de
combien coûtera réellement l'aménagement
global du pays ont thd on parle
aujourd'hui de 20 milliards d'euros
on parlait de 30 milliards voire
davantage il ya encore quelques mois une
étude précise sur ce sujet devrait
prochainement être rendu public
nous l'attendons avec une grande
impatience dans ce contexte les
écologistes seront particulièrement
attentifs à ce que les grands opérateurs
privés participent pleinement et
largement au financement des tuyaux
numérique dont ils seront les premiers
bénéficiaires
on le voit aujourd'hui les intérêts de
l'opérateur historique france télécom
orange dans la valorisation de son
patrimoine du réseau cuivre adsl entrave
les investissements nécessaires
il est donc urgent d'obtenir la plus
grande transparence sur la réalité des
réseaux très haut débit construit à ce
jour et sur les conditions ou des
projets d'extension à ces réseaux
transparence également sur les
contribuer les conditions d'attribution
des aides du fsn aux collectivités
territoriales pour la réalisation des
réseaux d'initiative publique
en conclusion le groupe écologiste
réaffirme son soutien à un développement
harmonieux des territoires sur le plan
numérique mais ils s'inquiètent de la
mise en place d'une logique qui
reviendrait comme souvent à privatiser
les bénéfices d'une telle opération est
à en socialiser les pertes
les écologistes en appelle donc un autre
modèle celui du service public local
les collectivités locales doivent être
en responsabilité sur l'intégrité de
leur territoire
l'intégralité de leur territoire
contrôler la qualité les tarifs les
investissements les conditions d'accès
dans le respect des principes du service
public
égalité neutralité une neutralité
continuité comme c'est le cas pour tous
les autres réseaux collectifs notamment
l'eau et l'électricité les réseaux de
télécommunications doivent être conçus
comme une infrastructure publique est
mutualisé sur la base de laquelle les
opérateurs organiseront les services les
prérequis techniques et juridiques à
cette organisation sont en place il faut
maintenant la volonté de les activer
je vous remercie merci monsieur gattolin
monsieur jean françois husson pour la
réunion des sénateur non inscrit
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues en octobre 2011 dans
le cadre des travaux de la commission de
l'économie et à la suite des rapports de
nos collègues bruno sido
bruno sido sur la téléphonie mobile et
hervé maurey sur la couverture numérique
je vous alertaient sur les enjeux
essentiels de ces problématiques pour
nos territoires
ces enjeux sont devenus plus prégnant
nous invitons plus que jamais à l'action
cette action madame la ministre je vous
invite à la conduire avec beaucoup de
pragmatisme pour la rendre applicable et
efficace la proche à cet égard retenu
par l'institut montaigne dans son récent
rapport proposant un new deal pour le
numérique qui incite je cite à repenser
l'économie et la société
grâce au numérique me paraît pertinente
y compris pour le cadre d'action est le
rôle dévolu aux collectivités locales
sur le diagnostic le constat est quelque
peu cruel pour notre pays qui accuse en
effet un certain retard retard dû à la
conjugaison d'un faible niveau
d'investissement dans numérique 1,7 pour
cent du pib alors que ces 2 5 à 3% aux
etats-unis un nombre insuffisant de
business angels et d'incubateurs à dz
trop dispersée et à des pôles de
compétitivité en surnombre nous devons
aujourd'hui rattrapé ce retard pour
permettre au numérique de contribuer
plus fortement à la croissance et à la
création d'emplois dans notre pays bien
sûr mais nous le devons aussi être
conscient du fait que ce rattrapage doit
s'opérer
alors que nous sommes dans un contexte
de fortes contraintes budgétaires qui
dictent donc des solutions pratiques
originales et peu onéreuse pour nos
finances publiques
l'état a en cette manière matière pardon
indéniablement un rôle stratégique
l'état doit d'abord être celui qui
organise les infrastructures c'est un
préalable nécessaire ou déploiement du
numérique
et prioritairement de la fibre
technologie la plus performante et aussi
la mieux acceptée par nos concitoyens
sur les préconisations il me semble que
l'état est aussi le premier acteur à
montrer l'exemple en lien d'ailleurs
avec les collectivités locales
notre administration doit ainsi
poursuivre sa révolution numérique ait
commencé à ouvrir ces données pour
permettre le développement de nouvelles
applications et de nouveaux business
models et je rappelle madame la ministre
que la couverture numérique haut débit
et demain très haut débit est une
condition primordiale au développement
économique éducatif et culturel des
territoires
cet aménagement numérique des
territoires est aujourd'hui la première
priorité demandé par les collectivités
territoriales au premier rang desquels
les communes il est donc indispensable
pour conforter l'attractivité économique
et donner de nouvelles perspectives de
développement aux territoires ruraux
comme aux villes et agglomérations car
c'est bien de cet aménagement que
dépendent l'efficacité des services
publics et des entreprises
la performance de nos établissements
d'enseignement de santé mais aussi
l'accès à la connaissance et à
l'information
dans mon département en
meurthe-et-moselle au delà d'un
engagement financier important de plus
de 70 millions d'euros les recettes
attaché à la commercialisation du réseau
restent faibles et menace l'équilibré
même du budget lié au partenariat public
privé
à cet égard que peuvent attendre les
locaux du fonds national pour la société
numérique madame la ministre je dirai un
mot de la couverture téléphonie mobile
qui au fil du temps prend un vrai un
certain retard et c'est un autre volet
de l'enjeu d'infrastructures du
numérique pour nos collectivités
l'encore madame la ministre la
persistance de zones blanches dont la
définition est manifestement aujourd'hui
trop restrictive dans nos territoires et
n'est plus acceptable alors que le
déploiement de la 4g va débuter en 2014
dans les zones les plus défavorisées il
nous revient à madame la ministre
sous la responsabilité de l'état avec
les collectivités locales de pouvoir
conduire un véritable
l'ensemble qui puisse apporter de la
cohérence aux différents calendriers et
aux différentes technologies utilisées
sur le territoire national enfin pour
que le traitement du patient si j'ose le
mot soit efficace il doit reposer sur
une thérapie ciblée peut-être
conviendrait-il plutôt que de nous
éparpiller comme nous en avons une
fâcheuse tendance que nous acceptions de
concentrer nos efforts sur des domaines
très spécialisés du numérique dans
lesquels nous avons une réelle touche
française comme pour utiliser un terme
français l'informatique en nuage et les
technologies mobiles
songeons tout petit pays qui est taiwan
qui grâce à une politique volontariste
et des investissements de masse s'est
hissé en quelques années au rang de
leader mondial des semi conducteurs
les enjeux sont trop importantes pour
notre économie mais aussi et surtout
pour les populations fracturé pour qu'on
se saisisse de la chance du numérique
pour assurer enfin l'équité territoriale
je tenais monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues offert
par de ces quelques éléments de
réflexion
en espérant que les réponses du
gouvernement sont de nature à nous
rassurer sur l'avenir du numérique dans
notre territoire national et sur tout
notre territoire national merci mon cher
collègue
la parole est à madame mireille schurch
pour le groupe crc
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues des tentatives pour
concilier l'ouverture à la concurrence
et la fourniture des services numériques
pour tous
non vraiment pas fait leurs preuves
c'est le deuxième rapport en deux ans
sans compter la vie du conseil économico
sociale qui dresse ce constat la france
accuse toujours un retard
je salue le travail réalisé par mes
collègues yves rome et pierre hérisson
qui nous permet donc d'avoir ce débat
extrêmement important pour nos
territoires dans notre assemblée à la
première fracture que nous connaissons
tous en termes d'accès au réseau s'en
ajoute une deuxième aujourd'hui en
termes de débit en effet les
technologies les plus répandues d'accès
à l'internet haut débit
l'adsl en particulier sont au maximum de
leur capacité
depuis l'arrivée de la fibre optique les
performances entre ces deux technologies
varie de 1 à 50
s'il existe bien sûr d'autres techniques
que celles du fibrage notamment la
montée en puissance sur le cuivre et les
réseaux mobiles 4g nous partageons
l'idée que le fibrage constitue
l'investissement d'avenir à réaliser et
j'y reviendrai toutefois s'il est le
seul moyen valable à terme pour assurer
une couverture très haut débit un tel
déploiement sur tout le territoire ne
pourra intervenir à notre avis à très
court terme tant les investissements
sont conséquents
madame la ministre on part de 20
peut-être 30 milliards vous nous le dire
et c'est pourquoi nous pensons qu'il est
aussi nécessaire de maintenir en emploi
raisonné et raisonnable de technologie
que d'aucuns qualifient de palliatives
pour ne pas laisser se creuser encore
l'écart entre les territoires
en effet aujourd'hui encore 1,7 pour
cent des foyers n'ont pas accès à l'adsl
six cent mille foyers n'ont pas accès à
plus de 512 kilo bits
cette situation pose de manière accrue
la nécessité de reconnaître l'accès à un
débit minimum pour tous comme éléments
du service public ou service universel
l'annnonce du président de la république
de réduire le temps de déploiement des
réseaux sur l'ensemble du territoire à
l'horizon 2000
22 et non plus 2025 comme le prévoit le
plan national cela est une bonne chose
même si pour la majorité des acteurs et
notamment les maires ruraux l'invs
estime l'investissement dans le très
haut débit doit être réalisée dans les
cinq ans à venir
car pour eux c'est une véritable course
de vitesse qui s'engagent et qui
conditionne l'attractivité de nos
territoires
toutefois la question du financement
d'une telle ambition reste entière le
déploiement de ces nouveaux réseaux
représente plus de 20 milliards d'euros
d'investissements vous nous avez annoncé
madame à nice 3 milliards d'état des
aides de l'état
pouvez vous nous préciser votre cadrage
financier et comment financer la charge
restante par les collectivités
territoriales
elles agissent aujourd'hui dans un
contexte financier plus que contraint le
pacte budgétaire européen en cadres la
capacité d'intervention des états mais
aussi des collectivités locales cette
question se pose avec acuité si l'on se
souvient que le précédent gouvernement
avait refusé de taxer les profits
pourtant non négligeable des opérateurs
privés
irez-vous dans ce sens madame la
ministre de même qu'en est il de la
taxation d'une imposition plus que juste
des géants du net qui ne peuvent
s'enrichir en fait que grâce au
développement de réseaux fiables rapides
et neutre la question du réseau ne peut
être séparée du contenu pour notre part
si nous nous félicitons que le prix des
abonnements soit moins cher que dans le
reste de l'europe
moins cher ne signifie pas que cette
dépense ne pèse pas sur les budgets des
ménages
n'ajoutons donc pas une fracture sociale
à une fracture territoriale à un moment
où la question du pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens n'est pas qu'une question
rhétorique le rôle des collectivités
territoriales est aujourd'hui essentiel
pour lutter contre la fracture numérique
nous en convenons tous le jeu du maire
du marché n'a pas permis de parvenir à
une
ouverture totale et équilibré du
territoire que ce soit pour le haut
débit ou pour le réseau de téléphonie
mobile est sans doute encore moins
aujourd'hui pour la fibre optique
c'est pourquoi nous partageons les
doutes des rapporteurs sur la pertinence
du modèle choisi qui repose
principalement et en priorité sur les
opérateurs privés ce choix conduira
nécessairement un déploiement plus
rapide de la fibre optique sur les
territoires à forte densité de
population les départements ruraux et en
al'inverse délaissé ce mécanisme induit
donc une réelle inégalité des débits de
connexion disponible au sein même d'une
agglomération
les opérateurs privés n'ayant pas le
souci de l'aménagement du territoire
mais uniquement celui de la rentabilité
en ce sens nous partageons les
conclusions sévères des rapporteurs qui
démontre que ce schéma n'est pas adapté
qu'il est inefficace et contraire à les
quitter pour nous atteindre ces
objectifs nécessite donc une reprise en
moins en main du déploiement des réseaux
par la puissance publique rendant
nécessaire une stabilité tant en termes
d'environnement juridique en termes
financiers aujourd'hui les collectivités
territoriales qui ont la charge
d'assurer la cohérence des déploiements
et en dernier recours de prendre
l'initiative de projets sur les
territoires qui ne serait pas concernée
par l'investissement d'opérateurs privés
sont en première ligne
l'arcep recensait 215 projets de réseaux
d'initiative publique dont 111 couvrant
chacun plus de 60000 habitants
à cet égard l'auvergne fait figure de
premier de la classe madame la ministre
et vous le savez bien en termes de
tarifs comme le souligne le conseil
économique et social
cette intervention a permis d'aller au
delà des offres proposées par les
opérateurs privés et de faire bénéficier
les particuliers et les entreprises de
tarifs moins élevés pourtant l'action
des collectivités territoriales reste
contraint
d'une part par la priorité donnée aux
opérateurs à déployer leurs offres dans
les zones rentables mais aussi par
l'impossibilité d'intervenir dans ces
zones ainsi les opérateurs privés
peuvent aller là où ils veulent et comme
l'a dit mon collègue hervé montréal
instant je les mêmes la situation par
leur annonce de déploiement 7
cela nuit considérablement à
l'organisation d'une véritable
péréquation
de plus l'action des collectivités
territoriales est encadré par une
législation multiples nationales et
européennes complexe leur action ne
s'inscrit pas ne s'inscrit dans
l'entente ne s'inscrit pas dans
l'anticipation mais seulement dans la
réaction à une situation de retard ce
qui ne leur permet pas de porter une
stratégie pérenne de long terme
enfin concernant l'aide de l'état
portant sur l'établissement d'un réseau
par un opérateur privé de nombreuses
collectivités souhaitent être associés
au processus de décision
elle se positionnerait incident un
véritable rôle de co décision des
politiques publiques nationales à
l'échelle locale
nous prenons donc la pertinence d'un
opérateur de réseau unique ayant la
capacité de procéder à un aménagement
progressif de l'ensemble du territoire
l'application de règles complexes et la
présence de multiples acteurs ne
permettent pas à notre avis d'avoir une
vue globale du secteur numérique
la mise en place de réseaux publics est
préférable à l'octroi de subventions à
des opérateurs privés porteurs de leurs
seuls intérêts individuels c'est
nécessaire si l'on veut éviter les
gâchis due à la concurrence notamment
dans les zones rentables ou d'ailleurs
se superposent pléthore de réseau les
milliards de profits du secteur démontre
qu'une autre répartition des richesses
favorable à l'investissement productif
est possible et permettrait un
financement propre des infrastructures
de réseau nous appelons de nos voeux la
résurgence d'un état stratège
qui pilote coordonne et soutient
réellement l'action des collectivités
territoriales dans l'aménagement du
numérique de l'aménagement numérique du
territoire revêt un intérêt général
national je vous remercie
merci madame church monsieur alain
dufaut pour le groupe ump
sur président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues
il est vrai que le numérique que fait
désormais partie intégrante de notre vie
plus aucune action ne peut être réalisée
en faisant fi de cet outil devenu
essentiel voire structurant pour notre
économie et ce positionnement central de
l'activité numérique à donne désormais
un impact plus important sur
l'aménagement de nos territoires
le choix de l'implantation des
entreprises et le maintien de nos
populations
en effet notre mode de vie après un
besoin accru d'accès internet avec un
débit toujours plus important pour
échanger les données pour communiquer or
alors même que la france avait su
franchir la barrière du haut débit en
disposant d'une couverture extrêmement
satisfaisante doublé de tarifs parmi les
plus bas d'europe elle se trouve c'est
vrai aujourd'hui dans l'obligation de
s'adapter au virage du très haut débit
qui nécessitent il faut bien dire des
investissements colossaux les capacités
financières des collectivités
territoriales et ans a été dix mille
faut le rappeler très affaibli il est
plus qu évident que l'apport des
entreprises privées du secteur est
essentielle à l'effet la coopération
collectivités opérateurs apparaît bien
désormais comme la composante
stratégique de tous les projets il faut
effectivement mutualiser et si possible
par le biais de la contractualisation
pour autant une crainte légitime
pourrait exister de devoir les
entreprises du secteur public
ne décidez d'investir que dans les zones
denses seul rentable économiquement et
accentuer ainsi la facture numérique
mais force est de constater que les
stratégies d'investissement des grands
opérateurs privés dépasse le plus
souvent le cadre des cinq zones denses
c'est la raison pour laquelle si toutes
les collectivités et notamment bien sûr
les conseils généraux tiennent à
développer un réseau très haut débit sur
le territoire
il convient néanmoins de vienne pas
venir doublonner les réseaux prêts
existants ou en cours de réalisation
appartenant à des opérateurs privés qui
peuvent nous savons tous être dégroupé
et pour connaître ce problème de
doublons dans mon département d'origine
je ne peut qu'attirer votre vigilance
sur ce point qui engage financièrement
des collectivités dans la réalisation
d'autres avant de travaux onéreux sans
rire laporte président âgé qui dispose
déjà par endroits le nak six autres haut
débit c'est ainsi que dans le cas de mon
département un opérateur privé a déjà
son propre réseau haut et très haut
débit couvrant plus de 90% des lignes et
va encore développer une extension de ce
réseau pour autant le conseil général a
pris la décision de développer son
réseau propre délégué pendant 25 ans un
opérateur privé tiers en participant à
l'opération hauteur de 12 millions
d'euros d'argent public
non seulement je considère que le coût
pour la collectivité est conséquent
c'est évident mais je pense aussi que la
durée de la dsp est beaucoup trop longue
tant qu homme s'était dit tout à l'heure
les technologies peuvent évoluer à un
quart de siècle
il est pourtant évident que dans ce cas
de figure comme le souligne fort
justement le rapport de nos collègues
yves rome et pierre hérisson est commune
il conviendrait d'assurer la
coordination des investisseurs dans un
organe intégré l'état strates stratège
mentionnés dans le rapport reprendre
effectivement toute sa place en devenant
le véritable coordinateur permettant à
l'investissement en cohérent et
complémentaire des opérateurs privés et
des collectivités locales pour irradier
au maximum le territoire en technologie
très haut débit sans pour autant créer
des doublons créateur du surcoût
inenvisageable en ces temps de disette
budgétaire
je crois que nos collectivités doivent
veiller à l'égal accès de nos
concitoyens aux technologies de
l'information en permettant notamment
son développement dans les arrières pays
pour que les entreprises s'y maintienne
et s'y développent
mais également toutes les zones
d'activités industrielles afin de
maintenir l'avantagé compétitif qu'ont
certaines des entreprises l'économie du
futur est en grandement dépendante de la
vitesse de transmission de l'information
il est évident que nous devons réduire
au minimum les zones blanches pour que
nos entreprises aient accès à du très
haut débit sur l'ensemble du territoire
et ainsi conserver les emplois qui s'y
trouvent
mais je le répète sans vision globale de
l'investissement numérique intégré en
complément réseau public aux réseaux des
opérateurs privés nous aboutirions alors
un départ d'entreprise ou d'emploi de
certains territoires vers les seuls
territoires qui serait couvert par le
haut débit essentiellement situés alors
dans cette hypothèse la zone urbaine ou
périurbaine aussi ainsi ce sera ma
conclusion je considère comme grandement
nécessaire que l'état soit l'acteur
prioritaires du dossier pour coordonner
les investisseurs et les investissements
et l'idée d'un établissement public
haddock chargé de cette mission peut
donc être une bonne chose à la condition
sinequanone qu'il soit réellement
opérationnels que les collectivités
territoriales soit associée à ce comité
de pilotage national et que l'état
puisse effectivement réellement
intervenir si besoin en était je vous
remercie
merci monsieur dufau la parole est à
monsieur michel teston pour le groupe
socialiste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président messieurs les
co-rapporteurs dont je salue la qualité
du rapport chères et chers collègues
l'union européenne a fait prévaloir une
organisation libéral et concurrentielle
du secteur des télécommunications
ainsi les monopoles en place dans la
plupart des services de
télécommunications ont été supprimés et
le service universel n'a pu être
instaurée que pour la téléphonie fixe le
principe de liberté d'établissement des
réseaux interdit aux états membres
d'accorder des droits exclusifs pour
l'exploitation de réseaux de
communications électroniques
un opérateur ne peut donc être contraint
à se déployer sur une zone même peu
rentable il est également impossible de
lui en interdire l'accès quant aux aides
d'état
déjà largement contraintes elles ont été
de plus en plus strictement encadrée
alors que les énormes besoins de
financement pour réaliser de nouveaux
réseaux auraient dû conduire un
assouplissement des conditions de
l'intervention publique lors de la mise
en place du plan national très haut
débit
le gouvernement fillon appliqué à la
lettre ces dispositions très libéral ce
plan fait la part trop belle aux
opérateurs privés au détriment des
collectivités locales cantonnés dans les
zones peu denses
en outre les opérateurs privés peuvent
ne pas réaliser les investissements sur
lesquels ils se sont engagés dans les
zones amis ne pas encourir de sanctions
pour cela est bloqué ainsi tout
investissement des collectivités locales
si l'on ajoute le fait que le fonds
d'aménagement numérique du territoire
n'a jamais été alimentées ceci explique
que les projets de déploiement portés
par les collectivités
ce soit certes développer je citerai
ardèche drôme numérique bien sûr
mais les projets ne sont pas aussi
nombreux que souhaité dans ce contexte
peu favorable aux initiatives des
collectivités en matière d'aménagement
numérique
on comprend que les avancées en ce sens
adoptée par le parlement français
je cite l'article l 1425 tirer 1 du code
général des collectivités territoriales
ou encore diverses dispositions de la
proposition de loi pintât n'ai pas eu
tous les effets escomptés
il convenait de remettre l'ouvragé sur
le métier
je salue donc le pragmatisme et la
justesse de la méthode retenue par le
gouvernement pour élaborer la feuille de
route pour le très haut débit
non seulement il reprend la main mais il
se pose en garant de la bonne
coordination des initiatives publiques
et privées plaçant ainsi les différents
opérateurs sur un pied d'égalité avec
l'objectif stratégique d'assurer la
complémentarité des moyens pour couvrir
le territoire
l'action des collectivités locales en
matière d'aménagement numérique du
territoire est ainsi confortée
principalement par deux signaux forts
premier signal la reconnaissance de la
place des collectivités par le
renforcement de leur rôle opérationnel
et la sécurisation notamment juridiques
de leur action la nouvelle coordination
proposées en matière de planification
locale va permettre une meilleure
coopération entre collectivités sur une
zone donnée et ainsi offrir des marchés
cohérent et de taille correcte aux
opérateurs en plus des schémas
directeurs territoriaux d'aménagement
numérique qui sont conservés des
conventions de programmation de suivi et
déploiements vont être mises en place
leur négociation devrait être l'occasion
d'un dialogue entre collectivités et
opérateurs
ce nouvel outil sera un gage de
visibilité en fixant des engagements
précis de programmation de déploiement
avec un calendrier pour chaque phase et
des suivi détaillé
exécution des travaux les défaillances
éventuelles de l'opérateur relèveront
engagements contractuels dont le préfet
fera respecter l'application tout comme
l'opérateur pourra mettre en avant le
manque d'engagement éventuelle d'une
collectivité pour faciliter le
déploiement pour satisfaire au
nécessaire besoin de coordination et de
cohérence du développement des réseaux
un observateur des déploiements géré par
un futur épique permettra d'évaluer et
d'analyser la mise en oeuvre des projets
deuxième signal fort un soutien
technique et financier renforcé de
l'état le soutien technique reposera
essentiellement sur la mise en place
d'un référentiel technique qui visera à
la fois à proposer des recommandations
standard sur les processus
d'exploitation ou l' architecture
technique des projets et à mettre à
disposition une assistance à maîtrise d
ouvrage pour certaines collectivités
n'ayant pas les capacités techniques
suffisantes pour réaliser leur
déploiement
ceci devrait contribuer aussi à la
diffusion des bonnes pratiques
quant au soutien financier de l'état au
projet porté par les collectivités
il est renforcé par deux dispositifs 1
action auprès des fonds d'épargné
dans le cas d'une enveloppe de 20
milliards d'euros dégagés par
l'augmentation des plafonds de l'épargné
réglementée et deuxièmement l'apport de
3 milliards d'euros date sur 10 ans dans
les zones moins denses alors en
conclusion je dirais simplement que le
législateur a reconnu en 2004 le statut
d'opérateur aux collectivités avec
l'adoption de l'article l 1425 tirer 1
du code général des collectivités
territoriales en 2013 la feuille de
route le rapporte la sécurisation de
leurs actions ainsi que des soutiennent
techniques et financiers renforcés
élément essentiel pour leur permettre
d'exercer pleinement la compétence qui
leur est reconnu
les collectivités locales ont donc
désormais toute leur place dans le
domaine de la couverture numérique du
territoire
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur jean claude lenoir pour le
groupe ump
bien monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
cette nuit je fais un rêve et gt gt en
quelque part en avril peut être au début
du mois d'avril
j'étais à la veille des élections
sénatoriales qui peut être à les
conduire pour une troisième fois dans la
haute assemblée et autour de moi le
bonheur était partagée tout le monde
avait le très haut débit représentant un
territoire rural
je m'émerveillais de voir qu'au fin fond
des chemins ruraux des personnes qui en
1212 2013 réclamé le très haut débit
l'avait depuis déjà un certain temps
utilisé des équipements très
sophistiqués les enfants partager leur
temps entre les cours dispensés dans
l'école mais aussi devant des écrans
télévision qui grâce à des ministres
particulièrement audacieux dans le
domaine de l'éducation nationale leur
fournissait des programmes exactement
adapté à leur époque
bref le bonheur était total et filles je
me suis réveillé je suis réveillé ce
matin plutôt de bonne humeur parce que
le rêve me poursuivez et voulant
préparer mon intervention dans ce débat
j'ai commencé à reprendre mes notes
il y retrouver de l'intervention qui
datait d'il ya simplement quelques
semaines nous avons une table ronde au
sein d'un commissaire aux affaires
économiques russes d'intervention des
uns et des autres et là je dois dire que
le rêve a brutalement cessé
il a cessé parce que est apparu
clairement ce que ressentent quantité de
personnes dans ce territoire la fracture
fracture numérique hier en fait une
fracture on le sait territoriale
géographique et puis également fracture
sociale je suis ici madame la ministre
dans un esprit qui est empreint d'abord
de réalisme de pragmatisme
conscient que tout ce qui a été fait
avant n'était pas excellent convaincu
que les meilleures intentions sont
exprimées ici à cette tribu par des
collègues qui appartiennent à des
groupes parlementaires qui ne sont pas
les miens mais je rejoins encore plus
facilement ceux qui en sont membres ou
qui en sont proches mais je dois dire
ici que je suis le porte parole comme
d'autres lots étaient où l'ambition de
lettres des laissés pour compte et qui
ne supportent plus ce discours
lénifiants qui consiste à faire croire
que le très haut débit dans la plupart
des français l'ont certes quelques pour
cent de la population devrait encore
attendre quelques années
soyons réalistes soyons réalistes et
dans tous les territoires
des fois tu entends âme et l département
est moins bien servi qu'un autre
la plupart des départements comporte des
zones déficiente
ce qu'on appelle des zones blanches et
puis tout ça est accentuée par les
difficultés que l'on à avoir accès au
réseau de téléphonie mobile
voilà pour ce débat consacré à la
couverture numérique du territoire si
vous souhaitez le revoir il est
disponible en vod sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr à suivre
l'émission politique de la rédaction de
public sénat preuve par 3 qui reçoit
aujourd'hui dominique bertinotti la
ministre de la famille alors que le
sénat entamera à l'examen du projet de
loi ouvrant le mariage aux personnes de
même sexe des jeudis à partir de 16h
bonne soirée à tous